[Music]
jared is with us jared's in midland
michigan hi jared how are you
good sir how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so uh me and my fiance are getting
married here soon in july um and we she
just graduated college with a nursing
degree and i've got a house that i
bought before we met
um i also have a new truck and she has a
new car
so we together we have about 330 000 in
debt
we both just started jobs where we're
making decent money
we gross about 90 000 a year
and i guess we were just kind of
wondering
um
you know coming up on our wedding and
hopefully having kids here shortly in
the next year or two um how we can kind
of prepare for
a solid foundation financially
yeah well congratulations on the on the
engagement the wedding coming up so
out of the 3 30 of
debt what is what's in the cars and
what's in the student loans
so my house i owe about 100 000 on
her student loans are about 170.
my uh my truck's 33 her car is 12.
so okay
holy crap
okay yeah
how old are you guys i'm 25 she's 26.
okay so when you add that up does it
kind of scare the crud out of you
oh absolutely what about her
oh yeah probably her more than me good
okay because i don't want you to be
debilitated by fear but i want you to be
afraid enough to do something about it
so that's good
okay
is she in the nursing position you think
she's going to be in long term or is
this just like a stepping stone because
of
our degree i think she'll stay there
she enjoys the work that she does
she's
she makes about
uh
fifty nine thousand a year and you make
thirty
no net she makes like 59. um take home
probably like 41 ish
i may take home like 40. okay i thought
you said 90 gross
well yeah okay
yeah she makes like 41. i make like 48.
gross 90 net
19. that's what your take-home pay
take home yeah sorry yeah 90 net not 90
gross so you're making about 130 100 110
okay good yeah all right good so good uh
and what do you do jared
i'm a millwright
okay good
good all right
well the good news is in both of your
cases you probably can pick up some
extra hours
that are very very profitable hours oot
and both of these things pays very well
we don't want to do that long term and
we don't want to do it too much in your
first year of marriage but uh we want to
do it strategically to be able to exit
to be able to get rid of these debts i'm
not worried about the house the student
loan is a serious mountain the trucks
probably under the heading of sold
okay because you guys got to clean this
mess up the faster you're out of debt
everything but the house the faster
you're going to have amazing peace in
this household because you're you know
you're gonna be making over a hundred
thousand dollars a year with no payments
but a hundred thousand dollar house
payment yet that's a really good place
to be in at 25 years old it's not gonna
be 25 it's gonna be 27 it's gonna take
you two years to clean this up
or more uh but the 170 is a big number
and so what i always look at
mathematically that gives me uh great
hope is the size of the shovel you have
your income
household income versus the size of the
hole you're in
uh and and so you're in a really big
hole
but you got a good shovel
and so i'm not panicking looking at the
math okay uh but i do know you guys got
two
to three years of beans and rice
no life ahead of you to clean this mess
up and i personally wouldn't try to ride
a 33 000 truck through that i'd ride a
an 8 000 truck through that
okay how much that you can sell it for
jarrod do you know
um
probably 40 42. yeah they give you
enough combine of the car for cash and
get rid of a truck payment that's 700
bucks a month right that would be huge
that would be huge sure yeah
that moves the needle and then your then
you list your debts smallest to largest
that would just leave her car and the
student loans and we begin to attack
them get her car knocked out and then we
begin to attack these student loans with
the vengeance and don't go into debt for
the wedding jared don't continue to dig
in that hole
no our parents are uh oh awesome pretty
much cash flowing that's right that's
great very grateful for that that's
awesome um
so
she has an option to consolidate her
student loans which would drop her it'd
go from a i think a 30 year to a 15 year
but it would take it from like a 2 000
monthly payment to a 1500 monthly
payment that do you think
doesn't matter what i'm concerned about
here is the interest rate what's it do
to the interest rate
uh
nine percent ten percent before 10 to
four percent yeah the lower interest
rate is excellent 15 years doesn't
matter because you're going to pay them
off in three years you're gonna be 100
debt free in three years
okay
well so the other thing i was thinking
um her if she makes her minimum payment
on our student loans for ten years her
work will pay it off is that we're not
writing that out
absolutely
no her work won't pay it off you're
talking about the federal government
paying it off and they have not been
doing that there's a 97
turn down rate on that plan it is a
failure okay so no we don't we don't let
somebody else clean up your deal you
guys got to go clean this mess up and
here's the thing a little bit of ot on
both of you we can kick this thing
without you without you completely
giving up your your newlywed year okay
but you can kick your income up another
50 grand pretty easy and that's where
i'm getting these numbers
okay
and so between the two of you and just
strategically pick some er work on the
weekends for her or something like that
you pick up some just some straight old
ot i'm sure it's available to you right
now because everything's gearing back up
no pun intended in your case but the uh
uh
but the you know the the uh you guys are
in you got great careers because you got
a lot of opportunity here to clean the
mess up and so but here's the thing
there's a direct correlation by how
intensely you attack this
and how fast you get out number one and
if you get out at all number two
the probability of completing it
is tied to your intensity and
the
speed at which you complete it being
debt-free it
um is tied to your intensity so i want
you guys to sit down have a very
detailed plan and attack this we're
going to help you we're going to give
you financial peace university as a
wedding gift okay
free oh thank you and the two of you
that's awesome yeah the two of you go
through that and um that's good
pre-marriage counseling it's going to
teach you to work together as a team to
accomplish a goal it's gonna be great
for your relationship anyway but it's
also gonna
normalize this process because what
you're getting ready to do
none of your friends are gonna be doing
they think you're gonna think you joined
a cult
sure
i mean you sold your truck have you lost
your mind you know that kind of stuff
let me tell you jared you guys together
like just to speak even more on that
sacrifice like this is the time to do it
as newlyweds before kids like if you
have the bandwidth to do it do it do it
now because you're gonna fast forward in
four years and you're gonna have a baby
on the way you guys are gonna have no
payments and the the the level of peace
that you will have so much more
doing it now
versus waiting it out because i mean we
talked to so many people that are
getting on debt and they have the kit
and they have kids and they're doing it
and it absolutely can be done but god
they look back like why didn't we start
this sooner so the sooner you guys can
do this the more intense you can do it
and shake hands and say okay we're in it
we are in it and we're going to complain
together we're going to be in it
together we're going to celebrate
together we'll be tired we're retired
together but like this is our journey
and two what it will do for your
marriage you guys working on the same
team with a huge goal like this and to
accomplish that your first couple years
of marriage is it will do so much for
you guys i mean it will it will it will
unite you guys in a whole other way
versus if you kind of just were like ah
we're okay with it it's fine and just go
through life so there's there's a lot of
pros here you guys have you said you're
25 right
yes sir okay so when you're 30 here's
what it's going to look like if you do
this
you're going to be making without
overtime
150 to 170 000 a year
you're going to have no payments
except a little bit of a house payment
left
and
you may even have it paid off
and and you're gonna have forty or fifty
thousand dollars in the bank
and you're gonna have learned to work
together you're gonna go on great
vacations you're gonna be on your way
are you driving that truck again jared
exactly you're gonna be on your way to
being a millionaire in no time that's
what five years from now looks like but
you got some hills to climb between now
and then hold on uh we'll have austin
pick up get you guys signed up for our
gift of financial peace university